welcome teachers for this short guided
meditation
remind yourself that meditation there's
no right way to do it
it's just an opportunity to
still your mind
take a break from all the thoughts
that you normally have the planning the
to do's of the future
thoughts of the past
and just be in the moment
and be still
so let's start
by taking a few deep and controlled
breaths together
in through our nose
hold
and out through our mouths
in through our nose
hold
and then out through your mouth
now i encourage you to continue to
breathe
in a deep
and controlled
way
but as you do so try to put a smile on
your face
it might feel a little artificial
but i promise it'll actually feel good
even if your mood might not have made
you want to smile just put a big
cheesy smile on your face as you
continue to breathe in
and out
so as you go through the rest of your
day
encourage you to take breaks like this
moment of pause
moment of stillness
approached with a sense of acceptance
a sense of curiosity
even a sense of humor
and remind yourself that as a teacher
you give so much of yourself to others
but you need to have a source of energy
and so for their sake
it's important that you take care of
yourself
it's important that you give your mind a
break
and be in the moment
in a moment of stillness
and acceptance
maybe in a little way resolve and
refresh everything that's going on
to tackle the day
the weeks the months ahead
thank you